I am Florence Pugh and I'm here with
BuzzFeed to play with some puppies
fun fact our dog Billy we fostered we
Foster failed because we then adopted
her and we weren't supposed to adopt her
and so my love for puppies is great and
I'm worried that I'm accidentally gonna
go home with a puppy
should I get a crate just in case so I
like I'm prepared oh my God I can't look
oh my God
oh
my goodness that's so
High Smosh you're so pretty
who are you hello oh my God puppy
[Music]
this is cruel guys I can't answer the
question I I loved um how far I would
have to go as a performer I loved
I loved how uh I was able to just be
bare-faced and I suppose just be raw and
open and honest and and Zach gave me
next question I can't think
so funny enough after reading the script
I was inspired to try and figure out
what headspace this character was in and
so I I wrote that song for the movie in
the headspace of Alison which was a
unique situation that I'd never ever
been in before and thankfully uh Zach
gave me the space to do that
so I was very very grateful oh you like
nope that's my booby you can't do that
that's not allowed oh my God
[Music]
I have the first movie I ever was in
called the falling the first scene I'm
ever in Maisie Williams and I are
carving our initials into a a piece of
tree bark but because we couldn't
actually use the real tree bark the
Prosthetics team made a prosthetic on
the tree and we were carving our names
into a pretend bit of
oh it's okay don't worry it's just a bit
of paper and they let me take the
prosthetic home so at home I have the
framed prop in the first scene I was
ever in
I would love to do a regular cooking
show that would be like honestly a dream
of mine and hopefully it's gonna happen
hey what's this what's that what's that
I had no idea that Paddington himself
was going to Tweet Me Maybe One Day I'd
actually like to make my marmalade with
them that would be a completely bizarre
moment in my life what's that yeah it's
good that here's the heart yeah
[Music]
Ashley Park I'd love to have Ashley Park
on my cooking show because I think it
would be
pure hectic Mania and I think that that
is oh hi babe it's all right and I think
that it would be hysterical and I don't
know if she can cook so that would be
even funnier
we eat all the macaroni also there was
this one take where when I come in the
room and Haley is supposed to be unaware
that I'm there and she throws the
Sriracha at me there was one take where
she went to go and do the action of
throw the sriracha and the Sriracha
bottle wasn't shut and so Sriracha flew
around the room and in her hair and that
was just pretty hysterical because it
was very unspilike of her
dive we no I I made that up
well because I was I wanted to eat the
mac and cheese they were like you don't
have to eat the mac and cheese if you
don't want to and I was like are you
kidding I get to eat mac and cheese all
day with Sriracha on it so I was like
well where's the fall
[Music]
it was amazing I mean it's it's
hey no secret that Greta actually wrote
that speech that morning like 10 minutes
before we were supposed to shoot she was
like Hey so you're gonna say this now
and this is how it's gonna be you need
to go and learn this and we're going to
shoot it in like 10 minutes so I was
like okay can you just give me maybe 12
minutes and I will go away and try and
learn as much as possible and I did I
went to the corner of the room and I was
just
what's this go
they don't like to go and get things do
they what's this hi hi
I think you're my favorite
oh my God I know that's my mic pack you
can't do that that's silly
I'm sorry
this is a great premise by the way
um I'm not sure you're getting the
answers you actually won reuniting with
Timmy was fantastic we'd go and uh have
goulash and drink beer and just chat
about life I hadn't seen him in so long
and um it was just so wonderful to see
how much he'd grown and it just he no
that's my my heart you can't do that and
just the set that He commands and the
space that He commands and it was just
so cool to see this person I'd met like
four years ago flourish into this just
incredibly present focused and
professional actor which of all the
things he was before but like leading
the June set is huge you know it's a
massive massive production and it was
just really cool to see my friend doing
it so well
oh
probably had to be Venice that was an
incredible accomplishment from like both
my Glam team and Valentino and just the
the timing of it all like it was pretty
special
you know I actually hadn't met him until
the day before the rehearsals and he and
I are doing a movie together but I don't
know if the academy knew what
hi oh you're so pretty you're so pretty
yes you are you are you're pretty too
you're pretty too yes you are yep the
academy didn't know
the Academy I don't think knew that we
were going to do a movie together
and so it was kind of like weird
circumstance and then we got to meet
which was great and we got along and I
take the piss out of him and he'd take
the piss out of me it was like Wicked it
was perfect no that's my left you can't
do that that's naughty
oh my God she comes alive on the carpet
that truly comes alive and it's just
been such a wonderful poo time poo time
I'd do it right there as well if I were
you don't you worry
no no no no no no no no to be fair I get
it guys you know frantic playing it all
got very dramatic for a second in it and
you did it in the perfect spot
out of frame don't put your feet in it
because then I can't cuddle you
well it'd have to be the No No we're
having a cuddle no we're having a cuddle
with it what's up yeah
it'd have to be the first one just
because it was so bizarre and amazing
and she just owned that carpet and she
kept on going up to like all of the
stars and being like I'm a star now ow
no no no no
and then of course when she did it again
in London no no no drop
wow
wow some assaults
um yeah the London one was pretty
amazing and also when I went to Ireland
she had a fan come up to me and say is
Granny Pat here and I said no granny Pat
isn't here
shush
do you like me
I like you too
[Music]
oh there was this one day when we were
both strapped to a pole when the pole
was shut like falling through the air
and we were both had to be strapped to
each other so we were both strapped to
each other's crotches like crotch to
crotch and couldn't move for like hours
we were just hanging in the air and it
was one of those classic things where
like we kind of knew each other but now
we really knew each other and we were
just hanging there for hours and the
only thing we could talk about was food
or when we needed to go to the toilet
because it was not going to happen for a
long time and um yeah I mean there's
there's few people that you you would
end up no that's my dress you're not
allowed to do that
that you'd actually love being in that
situation with and Scarlett is
definitely one of them
yeah I have created playlists in the
past it's not like a creative playlist
for the role I created a playlist during
the time that I'm shooting and it
definitely reflects what I'm feeling or
how I need to be feeling and most of the
time it's like stuff that I've just
found or stuff that I've Revisited
you are precious too I guess I'm taking
you both home
I mean this what is going
this is a choice
yes mid-summer I had a lot of olafur
Arnolds in fact I listened to his latest
album that had just come out and it was
just I I anything Olaf Arnold's does
makes me just weep so that was perfect
for that movie
[Music]
I would love to do a play I'd love to do
a musical but I think the play might be
first it's definitely something that
I've been kind of really needing to do
for a while so I think that's probably
next on the cards
oh I mean obviously when everybody was
watching White Lotus it was White Lotus
but recently water Bible ow no you silly
munchkin
what's this one there you go but
recently I've been getting into
Housewives of Miami which is my uh which
is the thing hey no no we're not biting
we're having Carlos
ooh good question I mean it would have
to be Spider-Man I think they'd be so
silly together it would be so fun as
well and I've been desperate to meet Tom
for such a long time also I really think
Elena would be able to really really
take the best out of him in a really
good and healthy way so that would be
wonderful
[Music]
Zoe Lester Jones would answer right now
Jody Turner Smith or Ashley Park
[Music]
yesterday I met Adam Sandler and he
requested to quickly say hi to me before
he went on stage
and he said the user found my work and
his kids are a fan of Midsummer I was
like oh my God I grew up watching Adam
Sandler like he was our hero me and my
brother would watch all of his stuff and
just it was just kind of one of those
surreal oh my God I'm meeting my my
childhood essentially no I know that's
fun to buy but you can't
most definitely the the org you see
which sounds inappropriate to stay in
front of all these puppies so don't hear
but the orgy scene
[Music]
probably Downy from Midsummer hey hey
I miss Danny I found it really hard to
leave her I felt like I had kind of
abused her in some way and so when I
wrapped I found it no no what are you
skipping for I found I felt very guilty
leaving her actually that's probably
just to show like how deep it went and
how far I went with the character that I
felt guilty leaving her on her own
a good person is in theaters now you
need to say your line now
okay and a big shout out to North Shore
Animal League America you can adopt
these puppies and have as much fun as
I've had maybe don't have someone ask
you questions whilst you're playing with
them it's very hard
no not my skirt thank you everyone are
we done are we cut okay cool
go
take you to I can't take you too
[Music]